[Musique]
le journal de l'afrique en direct du
studio jean karim fall à paris soit il
est bienvenu sur france 24 à la une ce
soir la crise entre kinshasa et kigali
la tension ne baisse pas d'un cran le
rwanda affirmé qu'il riposterait en cas
d' attaques sur son territoire à partir
de la république démocratique du congo
pour rappel les deux pays s'accusent
mutuellement de soutenir des groupes
rebelles à leurs frontières
l'interdiction de manifester maintenu en
guinée l'onu avait sommé les militaires
au pouvoir de lever cette interdiction
mais ces derniers ont décidé de la
maintenir la correspondance à conakry
dans un instant enfin nous irons au
bénin où les entreprises ont décidé de
faciliter la vie des femmes employées à
certains ont même décidé de leur ouvrir
des postes à responsabilité reportage à
cotonou dans notre correspondante
emmanuel sur zoug
pas d'accalmie chez entre le rwanda et
la république démocratique du congo
depuis quelques jours les deux voisins
s'accusent mutuellement de déstabiliser
l'autre en soutenant des groupes
rebelles aux frontières des deux pays le
ministre rwandais des affaires
étrangères vincent biruta a appelé hier
à favoriser la voie du dialogue tout en
affirmant que son pays se tenait prêt à
riposter en cas d'agression lors ambert
stecher avec les images de notre
correspondant à un gommage justin kaboom
face aux accusations de kinshasa le
ministre rwandais des affaires
étrangères dément un quelconque soutien
de kigali aux rebelles du m23
il n'y a aucun soldat rwandais en rdc il
ne peut donc y avoir aucune
collaboration avec des cons parme est
présent dans l'est de la rdc et
s'intéresse depuis plusieurs jours les
autorités congolaises accuse le rwanda
de soutenir l'insurrection du m23 sans
pour autant apporter de preuves malgré
les protestations de kigali des milliers
de manifestants ont défilé mercredi dans
les rues de bukavu pour afficher leur
soutien à l'armée congolaise et dénoncer
l'ingérence supposée du rwanda face à
cette montée des tensions les nations
unies ont lancé mercredi un nouvel appel
au calme et réitéré le soutien de la
monusco aux forces armées congolaises
la monusco à utiliser tous ses moyens y
compris ses hélicoptères pour riposter
aux attaques lancées contre elles et
soutenir l'armée congolaise il faut au
plus vite engager la désescalade et
assurer une réponse régionale et
internationale
la résurgence du m 23 ans est restée à
raviver des tensions historiques avec le
rwanda voisin les deux pays s'accusent
mutuellement de soutenir des groupes
armés sévissant sur leur territoire
respectif
alors que le ton continue de monter et
l'union africaine a récemment lancé une
mission de médiation
porté par le président angolais il a
obtenu mercredi un accord de principe
pour une rencontre entre paul kagame et
félix tshisekedi dans les jours à venir
et puis sachez que la république
démocratique du congo a accepté de
libérer les deux soldats rwandais détenu
à la demande du président angolais et
joão lorenzo pour je cite réduire la
tension dans les relations entre les
deux pays
cette attaque aux maliens casques bleus
de la mission des nations unies a été
tué et trois autres blessés mercredi
matin c'est leur convoi qui a été ciblé
à kidal les soldats de maintien de la
paix visés font partie du contingent
jordanien de la minus ma
les militaires au pouvoir en guinée
répondent à l'onu les nations unies qui
avait appelé lundi le pouvoir guinéen à
rétablir le droit de manifester à la
télévision nationale guinéenne les
militaires maintiennent cette mesure les
explications de notre correspondant à
conakry mali diakité
la décision des militaires au pouvoir
est ferme et catégorique aucune
manifestation ne sera autorisée pendant
cette transition à travers un communiqué
publié dans la nuit de mardi les
militaires justifie cette mesure par le
fait que de 2010 à 2020 en la guinée a
connu plus de 700 manifestations
violentes qui ont occasionné des
centaines de morts dont les
circonstances ne sont pas encore
élucidées les militaires estiment que le
conseil national de la transition et le
cadre de concertation mis en place sont
suffisants pour je cite débattre des
contradictions et des incompréhensions
en toute sérénité cette sortie
médiatique selon plusieurs observateurs
sont comme une réponse à l'onu qui a
appelé les autorités guinéennes à la
révocation de cette décision
d'interdiction des manifestations
politiques à signaler que la décision
intervient alors que de nombreuses voix
s'élèvent pour dénoncer la restriction
des libertés publiques dans le pays
dans la seule actualité en bref et en
images ouverture du procès de françois
bay à l'ancien monsieur sécurité du
président félix tshisekedi en détention
depuis quatre mois doit pomper vendredi
à kinshasa devant un tribunal militaire
françois bay a été accusé avec d'autres
personnes d'avoir formé un complot entre
la vie ou contre la personne du chef de
l'état fin de citation cette
manifestation au soudan des centaines de
personnes parmi lesquelles des partisans
de groupes islamistes se sont rassemblés
devant la mission de l'onu à khartoum
ils appellent ils appelaient au départ
de son émissaire dans le pays le conseil
de sécurité de l'onu doit se pencher sur
la prolongation de sa mission au soudan
au delà du terme de son mandat
initialement fixée au 3 juin prochain
la croissance du maroc sera plus faible
que prévu une sécheresse exceptionnelle
une mauvaise récolte et une flambée des
prix alimentaires provoquées par la
guerre en ukraine en sont responsables
après une récession en 2020 et 1 rebond
en 2021 le royaume chérifien va devoir
revoir ses prévisions à la baisse
au kenya un rappeur s'engage contre
l'abstention il a lancé une campagne
pour inciter les jeunes du pays à voter
lors de la prochaine élection
présidentielle qui se tiendra en août
mais beaucoup de kenyans qui se disent
déçus par leurs dirigeants politiques
hésitent encore
râpé pour encourager la jeunesse kényen
à s'exprimer à son tour lors de la
présidentielle d'août prochain voici la
mission de henry en ga nom de scène
octobre iso
nous faisons comprendre aux jeunes
qu'ils ont un grand pouvoir le plus
grand pouvoir qu'un citoyen puisse avoir
c'est à dire de limoger et d'embaucher
nos dirigeants font
ce n'est pas un acte anodin
et ça ne se produit que tous les cinq
ans
de pouvoir choisir et faire avancer ce
pays dans une nouvelle direction
mais seule une centaine de personnes sur
les 500 qui ont assisté à ce concert on
finit par s'inscrire sur les listes
électorales un symptôme d'un malaise
plus large
2,5 millions de nouveaux électeurs se
sont inscrits pour voter alors que les
autorités espéraient atteindre 6
millions d'ici le mois de juin cette
absence de participation pourrait
s'expliquer par un manque de confiance
dans le système politique alors que les
conditions de vie des kenyans empire
j'ai voté aux dernières élections
puisque j'avais une carte électorale et
les élus ils nous ont déçus ils n'ont
pas aidé le pays donc cette fois je ne
me suis pas inscrit pour voter car je
n'ai pas l'intention de voter cela n'a
aucun intérêt de nombreux jeunes disent
ne pas se sentir représenté par les deux
principaux candidats le vice président
william ruto et l'ancien premier
ministre aille là odinga des figures
connues de lectorat depuis des décennies
au kenya
comment imposer une parité hommes femmes
dans les entreprises c'est simple en
faisant en sorte de faciliter la vie des
femmes qui travaillent au bénin c'est la
volonté de plusieurs entreprises
reportage de notre correspondante
emmanuel sotchi
chaque matin car elle cette bo dépose sa
petite fille de 3 ans dans une crèche
pas comme les autres la particularité de
cette garderie moderne c'est qu'elle a
été aménagé sur le site de l'entreprise
ça me permet aussi
produits tv la maison et à
1h10 si c'est un peu plus difficile de
prendre de ses nouvelles par la voix la
pause mais là elle est juste à côté ça
me rassure dans cette entreprise de
services où près de 40% du personnel est
féminin la direction cherche ainsi à
développer la parité professionnelle car
dans les sociétés africaines la pression
sociale peut être un frein quand on est
mère de famille en est dans une
génération qui ont envie de prendre leur
avenir en main donc là elles le prennent
d'autant plus volontiers qu'on leur
donne ce support il est temps que tous
les chefs d'entreprises comprennent qu'à
un moment donné on doit essayer de
participer à cet équilibre hommes femmes
au travail dans un environnement où la
femme obtient difficilement la place
qu'elle mérite le concept de la rse la
responsabilité sociale de l'entreprise
contribue à bousculer les préjugés la
féminisation de la gouvernance permet
aussi à l'entreprise de se poser surtout
dans l'entreprise as porté
au nord de cotonou la direction d'une
entreprise de btp a pris la décision de
féminiser des postes de commandement
cette électronicienne est la première
femme à diriger une centrale à béton et
la même entreprise à plat si cette femme
ingénieur à la tête d'un chantier au
coeur de la plus grande ville du bénin
on a une autre manière d'approcher les
gens avec qui on travaille
et du coup de leur faire aller
là où on veut de leur faire atteindre
des objectifs parce qu'on parce qu'on
les approche différemment et je trouve
que les manades maculinea quelque chose
quelque chose de très pragmatique les
femmes en apporte au quotidien ce
qu'elles ont lassé précieux dans le
développement de nos économies donc
c'est tout à fait normal que dans les
entreprises comme les nôtres qui sont
dans le btp que ça se ressent dès 12 ans
au bénin 67% des entreprises se seraient
engagés dans une démarche rse mais il
reste un gros travail de sensibilisation
et de formation
la majorité des organisations qu'il
appliquerait serait en partie des
multinationales des ong et des groupes
étrangers
qui a dit que nul était prophète dans
son pays regardez ces images du retour
de francis kéré au burkina faso
l'architecte est le premier africain à
remporter le prix pritzker la récompense
la plus prestigieuse de l'architecturé
il a été accueilli et mam a clamé c'est
à ouagadougou la capitale burkinabè
écoutez le
sentiment de fierté
un sentiment de grand respect et quand
grand sentiment de reconnaissance à ceux
peu
dont fait partie ma famille qui m'a
encouragé et l'esprit combatif qui
m'accompagnait et revenir aujourd'hui et
rencontrer les autorités du pays mon or
une fois encore et sa mère dans l'espoir
et ça me dit ah je me sens sur le sol
burkinabè au sol où je suis né et je
voudrais dire simplement merci
voilà on termine en musique avec le
dernier clip de dj snake ça s'appelle
disque au maghreb et ce nouveau morceau
a été tournée en algérie un hommage à
ses origines l'artiste de 35 ans les a
toujours évoqué avec beaucoup de fierté
disque au maghreb met en avant les
belles sonorités de la musique
algérienne un bel hommage aussi au rail
originaire de la ville d'oran dj snake
pour info sera en concert au parc des
princes le 11 juin prochain à valence
quitte en images c'est la fin du journal
de l'afrique restait avec notamment
quelques instants la suite de paris
direct avec audry racines
[Musique]
vingt ans après la fin de la guerre
l'angola n'a toujours pas tourné la page
malgré le silence des armes les
stigmates sont encore bien présents
à nos fans nous faut renouer vers la fin
du mois ceux qui ont lutté pour leur
pays se sentent délaissés alors que la
corruption continue amplifier les
inégalités
mais une nouvelle génération semble
prendre le relais de la contestation
avec toujours cette même idée en tête
billet retour en angola à voir sur
france 24 et france 24 points comme